good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Tuesday post toastoween
hope everyone is feeling okay after the
come down of Chester win 2022 I know I'm
feeling the come down for sure it's a
come down but on the bright side it's
November it is November you're crazy
the weather outside is weather but the
weather is so weather
since we've no place to go listen to the
toast through the toast toast I have to
work on that yeah you could have just
said like listen to the toes but like
Let It Snow like snow has the same
intonation as toast okay so let It Snow
White Chocolate yeah something like that
sometimes the simpler option is the
better one ain't that the truth today's
a big day not only is it the day after
toasting which everyone's talking about
um it is the day that Jackie hopefully
gets her learner's permit which is the
first step in a long journey to getting
your license you have your test today
I'll be driving you there and we
everyone at the chest we are all wishing
you a huge thank you so much I've been
cramming for my tests there's so much
information to learn and I just like a
sponge I want to absorb it um but I only
have so much time yeah so I read the
handbook last night it's a hundred pages
of information I read like 70 pages I
have to do the next 30 okay honestly
like I do I feel I don't remember taking
the test so I don't can't say this for
certainty I feel like you're like
overthinking it I'm definitely
overthinking it but they really do ask
like obscure questions like dead ass
like what if you fail from the handbook
no if I
if I fail I'm gonna be heartbroken
I will literally die if you fail that is
the funniest thing right I've been
vlogging my journey and we'll continue
the Vlog today speaking of patreon
content uh last night we just like
dropped the most amazing podcast episode
with Olivia our sister who just gave
birth she sat down with us last week to
talk about her pregnancy her birth story
why she kept her pregnancy relatively
private this time and how her experience
this time around was very different from
the time before and it was really
amazing
I mean people love Olivia even when
she's you know talking about
less important things but she's really
sharing it all on this latest patreon
episode so once you're done listening to
this and make sure to listen to the
whole thing because I have a feeling
it's going to be spectacular no and I
have a feeling like it gets better as it
goes you know as it always does right uh
head over to patreon.com the toast to
listen to that and then you can also
consume all of the content from the past
five years but also our October content
was super premium why do you want my
coffee because look are you gonna lay
your cards again okay let me take one
sip oh my God I can't do anything in
this house without being monitored
you're gonna touch it on the top which
is where I put my mouth so
great Perfect Look at that yeah I need
to make space for Theo so I thought why
not create a sign you need to make a
seat at the table for him yeah no
because the thing about the toast is
like there's a seat for everyone but
mostly Me and Jackie yeah yeah our seats
are like the most important biggest ones
yeah and then we have some like uh
folding chairs
for anyone else who wants to join but
the Brethren stay on the thrones with us
and the Brethren stay winning they were
really the stars of toaster wind
yesterday yesterday was a crazy day
because obviously we did toasty wean but
yesterday was actual Halloween and when
you have children like Halloween hits
different
um it's way worse like it's not fun like
I think that it reinvigorates your joy
for Halloween I feel like the last few
years I've only dressed up for toast
weed I didn't like go to any parties or
dress in other costumes except like now
that I'm thinking about it I did uh but
still like it's not like how it was when
you were young and I feel like once you
have kids you start to see it through
their eyes again it's fun once more and
it's literally like the best day of the
year you just walk around collecting
candy well I don't want to spoil
anything because we did Vlog our entire
Hollow weekend
um we're like such vloggers we have so
many Vlogs like in the work right in in
production in production yeah
yeah some of them are in post-production
yeah no I was getting to editing last
night I need just your sign off before I
can upload it but we this was our first
year like obviously you're a homeowner
now like we we're hosting
trick-or-treaters and we were so excited
like we were incredibly let down I don't
want to spoil anything but like it was
wild we were really let down but you
know what I was watching on Instagram
stories and Olivia Culpo also was let
down she said they got like two bags of
candy from different places they were so
excited and no one came now has that
always like is this like a a problem
adults have or has the culture of
trick-or-treating changed in the last
couple of years that or you over maybe
it was never that pop-in for a home
owner just the kids who goes
sporadically to other houses maybe it's
never been that exciting to
open the door on Halloween you know
maybe that's not where the excitement is
at and maybe I'm just like looking at it
through rose-colored glasses but like my
childhood like I just remember like when
we were on the streets like it was
literally packed like kids everywhere
but maybe that's just like how I
remember it and I'm gonna choose to
remember it that way because those were
glorious times I literally don't
remember other kids when we were
triggered oh I do because we only hunt
like we're with each other who needs
other kids no we were like very insular
like not looking for other friends like
we had four friends no for sure but I do
remember other kids around not with us
but like in the streets on their folding
chairs right right exactly
um so I hope everyone had a great
Halloween I did you know first Halloween
out of New York so hot it is so
[ __ ] hot I'm definitely ready
to come home really you know I'm ready I
miss my bed coming home tomorrow I'm
excited but I'm not even sad because
your ass is coming with me and that's
huge it's huge not your ass like the
fact that you're coming
that like that sounded misleading like
and that's huge yeah
an insult snuck in no you have a perfect
shaped ass like really Perfection
um so yeah we'll be doing toast New York
Thursday and Friday fabulous we have one
more episode here with these deer
flamingos which have really been such
wonderful companions wonderful wonderful
companions wonderful backdrop backdrop I
love The Vibes I love The Vibes as well
and the pink of the new of the Rebrand
really matches the pink of the flamingos
it wasn't an intentional connection we
made when we were you know sitting down
with our team of graphic designers but
then once we got to the new Rebrand we
did notice that this pink did kind of
hark back to the flamingos and that's
how you know a Rebrand is like gonna
work you know but then there's hidden
meaning when your brand is so authentic
things constantly line up that actually
is true because it's not contrived and
it's who you are to your core and one
thing about us is we're not [ __ ]
contrived not at all I bet some of you
wish we were contrived but we're not you
wish we were
um
so yeah no TV recap today what just what
like I think the field of TV is Shifting
is Beverly Hills is ending I have not
been keeping up with it over sorry ended
Potomac is on but like I just have
fallen short so like cities on and I
have
I've been searching for like one iota of
a [ __ ] to give the thing is you guys we
tried yeah I we really try I really
don't care so like I don't know if I'll
catch up but like until they start
talking about anything
no until until they stop talking about
anything other than Jen's trial like I'm
genuinely not interested you're
genuinely not I'm jinshan you and Lee
not interested understood so tell me
lies is over House of the Dragon is over
but new things are starting too White
Lotus just started yes I need to catch
up I think there's maybe two or three
episodes out there's one cool
um and so we could watch that week to
week that would be fun sure but you know
it all depends on the day of the week
Sunday and that would replace House of
the drag okay okay I'm here for that the
crown is coming back next week
the cranum is so excited I'm so excited
I need to like clear my schedule to make
time you know that's going to be like a
weekend Affair it's going to be glorious
absolutely glorious and then
what else winter house is on but we
haven't picked that up no I'm just like
really I'm being more selective I'm I'm
protecting my peace when it comes to
which reality shows I'm gonna watch it's
just I feel like for for a while it was
a little too much so I'm just protecting
my energy and I encourage all of you to
protect your energies it comes in waves
it really depends on like the franchise
I feel like two weeks ago we were
recapping so many things yes you know
when New Jersey zombie recap is New
Jersey is so good like so good New
Jersey stays winning and the thing about
New Jersey is there doesn't need to be
like a huge thing happening for it to be
good well that's the thing like I feel
like in the fandom like whenever people
talk about like the Crown Jewel see like
even the worst season of Beverly Hills
is so good and that's true but I feel
like really New Jersey does not get
enough credit I agree like I cannot
recall a recent season that was bad it's
just genuinely entertaining yeah and I
think a lot of that has to do with the
fact that like the group is partially
family so like they always have to be
together and it's like toxic it's really
good yeah and the men oh of course
yeah for sure that's really what sets it
apart
um so we've got a great show today I'm
so excited to talk about the Glee Story
like some bombshell
BTS facts and trivia came out
um from this Ryan Murphy interview he
was just sharing lots of tidbits about
glaze so gleeks unite he was on the new
Glee re-watch podcast yeah
um so that's something positive coming
from a re-watch podcast that's true I so
it's hosted by Jenna uskowitz and Kevin
McHale who played Tina and Artie and
it's the official rewatch podcast but
they also already had a podcast together
yeah but it wasn't about Glee yes it was
no it was about Duos right no because I
did the podcast and I think you made it
about Glee on your episode but it was
about Duo I didn't make it about Glee
they gave me an episode to watch like
they were re-watching and recap it
wasn't a rewatch it was like a recap or
whatever okay
um and then when I recorded my episode
it was a week that Nia Rivera passed
away so they never released it because
like there was more important things so
my episode never came out um so maybe
I'll be asked to go on this one I feel
like I need to remember the name I feel
like it was about doing but then you
went on it alone so that doesn't make
sense no it doesn't so I'll need to when
I pick up my iPad do a little Googling
yeah
um so we've got that we've got great
stories really we do and I think without
further Ado where are you right here for
another amazing episode with the stress
brother and we're just counting our
blessings because soon they will not be
here
with us while we do the toes Jesus
Christ because when we do it separately
like they don't show up to work they
don't they're so bereft they're so
competitive that they'll only work when
the other is working to show the other
one up everyone has a co-worker like
that you know what like competition
makes you thrive no competition benefits
the consumer right that's the saying oh
no the saying is competition benefits
the toaster
hundred percent right right so without
further Ado here are the past five
stories that you need to know
today's episode I just want to say like
I'm really not happy with where we
landed it's all in flex no you keep
saying that but you've been doing the
same thing for like two weeks but when
do I ever stay on one thing no maybe
maybe we should just say here are the
fast five stories that you need to know
maybe we can add a new button to the
sound board like clink or a button with
a song
a button with an original song
oh we could put on toast
yeah like just that one part of toast or
any of the songs that we've written for
toast Tunes yeah or just toast by
Claudia ashrae
sure sure well today's episode is
sponsored by framebridge framebridge
makes it easier easier than ever to
custom frame everything that matters
without ever leaving the house which
means that you can easily give a
thoughtful gift this holiday season so
we've been lucky enough to have a ton of
incredible experiences with people that
we love this this past year and if you
want to do something special for them
something that we've done
um is framebridge the perfect way to
frame what matters most so whether it's
a selfie of you and your best friend
someone's game-winning Jersey a special
anniversary dinner menu consider framing
it with framebridge
give them a gift that only you could
give so here's how framebridge Works go
to framebridge.com and you can upload
your photo or if you have a physical
piece to frame like a physical photo
they'll send you a complimentary
packaging to safely mail it in I just
want to say like framebridge letting you
frame photos from like your albums like
from the photos app on your phone is so
like they're living in the future we're
living in the past you know I think it's
the most genius thing and then I feel
like some of the photos I take like for
my Instagrams of like my family or even
just myself or Theo are better than like
who's engetti I don't know her you can
preview your items in dozens of frame
styles on framebridge.com you'll choose
your favorite or you can get your um a
designer to help you for free the
experts at framebridge custom frame your
item they'll deliver your finished piece
right to your door and instead of paying
hundreds at a framing store framebridge
starts at just 39 plus free shipping you
can order online or stop by a
framebridge store near you to work with
a designer in person so if you'd like to
get started today you can frame your
photos or give someone the perfect gift
this is your reminder holiday season is
upon us now would be a great time to
start thinking about gifts for husbands
wives brothers sisters grandmothers
grandparents
um framebridge is really really sweet
and it's really well done and it's very
affordable which I feel like framing is
not and it should be so if you want to
go to framebridge.com place your order
today and check it out
today's episode is also brought to you
by stamps.com seasonal excitement is
here or as some of us know it's seasonal
dread it's really starting to settle in
especially if you're a small business
owner so if you're slaying through
traffic to get to the post office if
your inbox is more like a blizzard than
a winter wonderland check out stamps.com
and get all your holiday mailing and
shipping under control sign up and
you'll be printing your own postage in
minutes stamps.com is your One Stop Shop
for all your shipping and mailing needs
get access to the USPS and UPS shipping
services that you need to run your
business right from your computer
there's no lines there's no traffic and
most importantly there's no hassle you
can even save money with major discounts
on USPS and UPS shipping rates up to 86
off it's a stress fees Free Solution
stress-free solution for every small
business use stamps.com to print postage
wherever you do your business all you
need is a computer and a printer
I need to like ship back some things to
my you know New York studio for my
Florida this is like a shipping magnet
no and I'm just like a transatlantic
like girl Coastal if you're running an
online store stamps.com Works seamlessly
with all the major shopping carts and
marketplaces you can use their switch
and save feature where you can easily
compare carriers and rates so you know
that you're getting the best deal every
time so this holiday season trade late
nights for silent nights and get started
with stamps.com today sign up with our
promo code toast for a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a free digital scale
there's no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the home
page and enter code toast you guess that
right you guessed that right stamps.com
toast stamps.com like making so much
easier one of the most difficult things
one of the most difficult times of the
year too oh Beyond that's a lot of
really great gifting like go if you need
gift ideas head to framebridge if you
need to share ship your gifts go to
stamps.com if you need gift ideas like
just listen to the toast oh yeah you
should do
a toast gift guide we've done that
before on patreon yeah oh we could start
thinking of it now so you could keep a
list it's hard for me to think of
everything yeah no I'm sit down to do it
I'm also not a great Gift Giver like
who's on God's green diddly daily Earth
do I think I am giving gift guide
recommendations I think of really good
gifts for people like at the complete
wrong time like I just thought of such a
good gift for Olivia but it's like
there's nothing coming up right and so I
need to write it down actually and then
sometimes I do that and it really works
out well but
I come up with really good ideas just
and it's not the time no but you're a
pretty good Gift Giver I would think so
especially for you yeah because I know
you so well you do how's my birthday
gift going it's doing really well like
really really well you know what I'm
sure that you're gonna head to the shops
of New York and buy your girl something
I don't need to unless you got something
already uh I don't really feel like you
know David's doing my secrets but just
know it's it's
I'm sure that you
haven't gotten anything yet so let me
just wow have ye little faith no I know
that I will have something on my
birthday like however you choose to go
about it I'm not offended by a
last-minute purchase it's not a last
minute purchase okay but if you needed
some ideas or no sure sure yeah like
just think home that's where my head is
at of course yeah like I the KitchenAid
mixer would have been great if I didn't
just get it for myself it's just hard to
buy something for someone who buys
everything for themselves you know yeah
no I that's true self-sufficient Queen
financially independent Queen but maybe
you've been staying in my home there's
something I didn't have no don't worry
like seriously don't worry
okay I'm not worried don't worry I'm
really not worried maybe something for
Strife why does it smell like like a
bully stick in here
I'm not smelling that maybe it's the
Bruno because Thea smells great maybe he
just enjoyed one did you see anything no
I didn't even give him one you were with
him all morning and all evening because
he's a traitor he's obsessed with me and
that's why I'm sad obviously I don't
want you to leave ever I want you to
move in with me but I'm really sad for
Bryce like that I'm leaving yeah and
that like the party is ending because
these last few weeks have been heaven
for him they really they've been heaven
for me too Bryce I love you dearly and
you know there's always a place in my
bed for you yeah I always spotted my
table in a folding chair on the floor
okay our first story some really
exciting news Taylor Swift has announced
her 2023 era's tour of U.S stadiums
Taylor announced this morning her long
rumored return to the road with an
outing dubbed as the era's tour
scheduled to hit U.S stadiums beginning
in March 2023 and running into August
with intern International dates set to
be revealed later the supporting acts
are very much all about The Sisterhood
with a host of Acts Taylor has
championed in the past opening acts for
the U.S leg of the tour are paramour
Haim Phoebe Bridgers B badubi girl in
red moon Gail Gracie Adams and Owen
Chrissy Abrams
yeah she's JJ Abrams his daughter nepo
baby Powers the music
um I don't know it but I feel like I
have something Margo loves her and she's
like literally the definition of an
impotence maybe like but I feel like I
actually know who she is I've I like
know her I don't know a lick of her
music
um and today was just a really hard day
to wake up as someone who's not a
Capital One card holder like it was
really really hard yeah and I feel like
when you go to tpg for all of your
points and cards advice and like he kind
of Led You Australia here because he
should have known don't get it twisted
like I will be using Brian's credit card
and then reimbursing him so he has
capital I don't even have to ask I know
he has a Capital One credit card like I
will be getting my way into pre-sale
like I know I saw a Capital One
sponsored it they got like premium
billing yeah because they didn't realize
that that would mean Capital One card
holders most of the time it's American
Express like for I feel like a lot of
tickets I feel like Ticketmaster is like
a big partnership I don't know why I
just always think it's American Express
but Taylor has her own deals like she
was on those Capital One commercials a
couple years ago so she obviously is a
big deal with Capital One I I should
have guessed but now it's like with with
these things like you can't become a
card holder and then become eligible
it's like for pre-existing card holders
darn darn darn so I feel like there's a
very small chance Ben might have a
Capital One credit card definitely not
um I will be asking Brian as well
um I will be getting pre-sale like I
will be scheming the system and I don't
want to hear any anything about it like
I'm gonna do I'm gonna figure it out
like I'm so
like I can't I'm also gonna like I'm
gonna see multiple shows okay well here
are some dates and she's going to
Arizona Vegas that sounds like something
to see uh Texas Arlington Texas Tampa
Florida Houston Texas Atlanta Georgia
Nashville Philly Foxborough
Massachusetts oh at Gillette Stadium not
at Foxwoods no that is confusing yeah
East Rutherford stadiums East Rutherford
near Jersey
Taylor loves MetLife Stadium well is it
a stadium in the truck like in the New
York area like it's the biggest one yeah
the Jets and the Giants play there there
aren't that many um
100 000 seat stadiums in New York it's
about yeah not for a concert because I
don't know if you sell the whole thing
even though people are now like guessing
that because her whole theme of like
midnights is like a clock it's gonna be
like a rotating circular stage which
means she could sell the entire
Stadium
wow and maybe eating each era is like a
different time oh yeah and that makes it
like hard to like know where to sit now
I want to say I love the concept of the
eras because you know Taylor Swift fans
we're so blessed like we've gotten in
the last four years like so many
different works of art re-records
original music
um
but like I am sad that like certain eras
like especially for me like folklore
Evermore that we're not going to get
like a dedicated ever More tour yeah
like how a normal celebrity does an
album and a tour an album and a tour and
Taylor is obviously not normal so this
this is really like lover
folklore Evermore Fearless re-record red
re-record midnights it's six albums in
one it's not gonna be 1989 it looks like
debut too no she put all of them on
there and like the concept of the show
that she explained it's like it's a
celebration of all of my eras right um
but she could sing songs from albums she
hasn't re-recorded yet right like people
do covers at concerts all the time yeah
no she can sing yeah yeah yeah no I do
actually do think you do pay for it
really I do think so like there's a
weird yeah
hmm there's something
um
I just do wish like we there's so many
recent you know works of hers that I
wish got dedicated towards the mostly
Evermore yeah but that would have been
an interesting it would have been
different it would have been like a bony
bear oh we had talked about this it
should have been at like an Amphitheater
where you could sit on the grass or like
a Madison Square Garden yeah an arena as
opposed to a stadium yeah because it's
not a stadium Vibe you just want to like
it's just such a flex that like Taylor
is out here
um like I think now is the third time in
a row because 1989 she did it with ex
maybe not 1989. exclusively Stadium
dates I think reputation was probably
the first time she did that because 1989
she played the Staple Center eight times
as opposed to just like Sofi Stadium
once and she is playing Sofi Stadium
twice twice which is so crazy so just
like such a flex to her like oh tour
gotta do just the stadiums you know
maximize my time maximize my profit also
yesterday was a big day for Taylor
because the Billboard Chart came out and
not only did you get the number one song
with anti-hero she occupies all 10 spots
on the Billboard charts four different
songs from midnights which obviously
she's the first person to ever do that
and it's just [ __ ] iconic it's
literally just iconic and it's the first
time there hasn't been a male on the top
10 Billboard charts in history and you
just you truly love to see it you love
to see it it was such a I feel like I've
seen that like infographic of the
Billboard charts a lot people are always
sharing like so excited my song what
number number two number one
um and I've never seen it like with just
the same person yeah it was really
iconic she's just it's like iconic era
you know
um
I just think it's iconic yeah I love the
concept of this tour me too especially
since like eras is such a
core part of her brand no that word is
really having a moment I think it's like
a Timeless word but you know people be
like I'm in my blailing era and this is
real is that yeah no and she really like
she's not even bandwagoning on like a
trendy word because she's been doing
this right and she every album for her
is an era so so I really want to wish
everyone luck on the pre-sale the
General on sale like it's gonna be a
bloodbath till the end and I will be
fighting with my sword till the very end
what city are you gonna go to other than
east Rutherford Nashville is on Margo's
birthday oh wow so I've already spoken
to the counselor about that idea
because I was like probably marketers
want to hang out with me on you know her
birthday so
um maybe I'll see like if anyone else
wants to go but she it was her idea and
of course I'm gonna be going to MetLife
Coolio Coolio I'm so excited this is
just it's a thrill there's just like it
feels overwhelming like she's a lot of
catching up to do you know and I'm sure
she feels overwhelmed Beyond but I think
this is a good way to organize it yeah
it's very organized as opposed to being
like what song's coming next
switching back and forth now she can
really get on every outfit for a huge
mood it's perfect I bet it's going to be
like a lot I mean all of her shows are
long but I bet it's gonna be like a
three hour concert
yeah yeah no one like she could go in
for like hour breaks yeah go to the
bathroom get snacks right like go to
some activations that's like what lover
Fest was initially supposed to be yeah
um also people are quaking because on
the list of openers there's power more
it's like they're only opening one show
the first one which is so unfair like
gotta go to Arizona because that's so
cool
um so they're not like really an opener
you know yeah it's just so crazy like
Taylor's out here like humbling Phoebe
Bridgers you know what I mean like
Phoebe Bridgers is like a huge act and
she's like now an opener yeah I'm trying
to see where she's opening and it
doesn't look like she's doing a lot oh
she's one of the East rutherfords oh and
I'm sure there'll be special guests do
you think oh of course of course of
course but not as much as she used to
but definitely like for maybe people who
she's collabed with like maybe Lana Del
Rey Stapleton oh Nashville is going to
be Chris Stapleton he'll be whispering
maybe like one song per tour she'll
bring out the person that she collabed
with oh I love that
loving being part of the strategy team
for team Taylor honestly like you're
really good at stuff like that like I
feel like you could work for Taylor
Nation you know I feel like I could too
love that for you except you're just
like a hater to your core so that's so
not true when it comes to Taylor no no
compared to you yeah since I don't love
her at the level that you do I'm a hater
compared to a lay person I'm obsessed
you're like such a hater it's disgusting
is disgusting
well I'm happy for everyone I'm happy
for me I'm going to try and is there a
Florida date there is Tampa in April but
like if you guys are going to Nashville
for snitch's birthday like why couldn't
I go because you never come anywhere
sure come you never I'm ready like you
never invite me great I'll tell Margo
she'll be thrilled to have someone else
to contribute to the price of the
tickets that's really what she's
bringing us she's bringing us for
financial support but it's okay because
as long as I'm included yeah like
you're not going to stop me from having
a good time no right like 100 100 can't
wait snitch to celebrate your big
birthday with you your big sisters love
you
foreign
tell her what we say on the episodes
please share with her that her quote Big
Sisters love her so much just let's all
send her messages like right now Margo
your big sisters love you so much she's
gonna be so confused
okay are you ready for our next story I
genuinely I truly am because we're
shifting gears because Migos rapper
takeoff has been shot dead in Houston
rapper takeoff best known as one-third
of the hip-hop group Migos was shot and
killed Tuesday Morning a rep confirmed
the hitmaker died in the shooting after
a fight broke out over a dice game at a
private party at billiards in Bowling
establishment in downtown Houston TMZ
reported he was 28 years old a rep who
was not authorized to speak publicly
confirmed the rapper's death Houston
police and a fire officials arrived on
the scene at 2 40 a.m following multiple
multiple reports of a shooting footage
obtained by TMZ showed Migos member
cuevo and others gathered around takeoff
who was lying on the ground oh God they
were there the clip reportedly showed
the group trying to move his body before
they put him back down and shouted for
help the man was pronounced dead at the
scene police said two additional victims
were transported to nearby hospitals
police did not release the identities of
those victims but said the person killed
was a man in his late 20s and would be
takeoff that is terrible like such young
people yes the victim's identity
identity won't be officially released
until it is verified by the County
coroner so it hasn't been fully verified
yet but this is what sources are saying
and what TMZ is reporting that's
terrible that's really horrible to me so
young I'm sorry excuse me
um so young and you just go out and
you're dead yeah it's terrible it's a
terrible story like I was looking there
are so many tributes already coming out
um I think this is like really shaking
people up no it's terrible
yeah it's terrible so we'll keep you
posted
um as they you know verify information
that comes out but just a really sad
news to wake up to
are you ready for our next story yeah it
is the story that was requested by
Claudia though I'm so happy to be
talking about as well Ryan Murphy wanted
Justin Timberlake to play will Schuster
and I just want to say you guys remember
I said like two weeks ago on the podcast
said to me will Schuster is Justin
Timberlake no no and when you said it I
was like oh my God like you're a genius
you said it I didn't even think I was
having an original thought like they
just are the same no I think that like
someone writing a character for Justin
Timberlake and then casting going out
and bringing back Matthew Morrison is
perfect casting yeah it really is so
Justin Timberlake as the Director of the
Glee Club back to Ryan Murphy initially
had in mind when casting the pilot for
Glee his hit dramedy on Fox during his
appearance on the first episode of the
podcast and that's what you really
missed oh that's a good name he admitted
that he had someone other than Matthew
Morrison in mind when he first went
looking for his choir director William
Shuster quote the pilot was written for
Justin Timberlake Mr Shoe Ryan admitted
for the first time to Kevin McHale and
Jenna uskowitz the hosts of the podcast
uh the episode ended at that point so
anyone who wants more details will have
to listen in next week okay wait I just
want to say like
Justin Timberlake like not doing the
role
is even better because I feel like what
made Mr Shoe like such a freak which is
really what what his character was was
that like he thought he was like a
Justin Timberlake type right so if it
was Justin like maybe we would have
people thought he was cool like yeah
because he's Justin Timberlake but the
fact that it was like you know Matthew
Morrison and every time he would like
dance and sing he thought he was Justin
Timberlake because that's like such a
teacher thing like yeah it was perfect
it was perfect but in hindsight I think
Justin Timberlake if it was offered the
role and he declined it I think he made
a mistake like uh Matthew Morrison won
an Emmy for his role as Mr Chu yeah and
the show was huge both in popularity and
in critical Acclaim like I don't know
what he was doing in those years but not
much nothing was bigger than Glee at
that time yeah no I mean it's never I
feel like um people are always talking
about this on watch trappings live like
as an actor who you know
acts for a long time like you're not
ever your radar for what's a good role
and what's a bad role isn't perfect and
sometimes you are going to pass on like
the role of a lifetime because you
thought it was going to be like some
dumb indie project and it ends up being
you know Superman yeah so no one can
really truly know it's unclear whether
he
turned down was unavailable right so
there's no way of knowing that but by
now next week I'm sure
um he's kicking himself
I'm sure probably not I'm sure he's like
no it wasn't the right role for me like
it wouldn't have been right still but
he's wrong yeah he's wrong you know just
to make himself feel better which I
respect because like you know everyone
has things in life obviously not on the
scale of like being cast in like a major
TV show but everyone has things in life
that like they wish they did at the time
like a regret you know for me the list
goes on I have it on my phone right so
um
I think a good way of coping with that
is like ignoring it you know yeah yeah
just sticking to your sticking to your
gun yeah but I do appreciate I'm
watching up inside because Andy like
plays a game he's like is it true that
you are almost this character and people
who acknowledge it and like acknowledge
it was like an enormous you know
misjudgment on their part I actually
appreciate that sort of vibe and I also
love knowing like who was up for certain
roles yes versus who got it it makes it
interesting to like see the vision how
they got to like see with with Justin
Timberlake like I can literally see it
literally they look exactly like the
same like cringy Vibe also Ryan revealed
that his Glee co-creator Ian Brennan
wanted shu to be a crystal meth addict
in an earlier dark version of the script
he said it was sort of like election but
the NC-17 version of show choir with a
weird protagonist who was unraveling
what I loved was the idea of kids in
high school it seems like shows that
work or TV experiences work feature
people going through first times that's
very true yeah no he basically he said
like the original idea for glaze like
not what it ended up at at all it was
like a very dark like weird show where
like this meth head was teaching kids
how to sing like honestly sounds so
funny um the way it ended is ended up
like Glee really was a perfect show so I
have no qualms but it is really
interesting to see like what almost was
you know yeah I want them to do like on
this podcast I know Jenna ashwoods
actually listens to the jokes like Jenna
if you're hearing this I want you to do
like a whole maybe like a couple of
episodes like a series on the cameos
like okay when they get to that episode
they will so are they going Episode by
episode is that what those is that what
a re-watch show is yeah they watch do
they do it on the office that's that's
what they do about the office yeah and
like OC OC one Laguna Beach one I think
there's so many
um and so since it was the first episode
they probably did the pilot and then
they had Ryan to talk about like what
the vision was okay also their other
podcast was called showmans
yeah they did recap episodes but I don't
think in in order got it okay it wasn't
a re-watch podcast it was just like a
glitchy fun things podcast now they've
been like formalized they have like the
official the official rewatch podcast
and I can't think of a more worthy show
I mean it's a ripe and the documentary
right and also it's like because it is
so recent it's like still top of mind
and it's fun to like put the pieces
together versus a show that was so long
ago that's like
it it you forgot how you felt at the
time and like the narrative and just
like the the vibe from Glee like is
still playing itself out of course like
the funny girl thing just re brought up
so much of the Glee plot line for so
many people so even though yeah it has
been however many years like we're still
talking about it literally every day
yeah every day I am it's and it's a show
that like has so much drama and like all
that stuff but it's also a show that's
never really been formally deep dived
into yeah so it's like I'm not even
getting fatigued by it you know it's
just it's a perfect show I also feel
like it's a show in a few years that
could be brought back
because it's just the same format like
Oh you mean with totally new actors yeah
like a reboot right like maybe even Mr
shoe and Coach Sue and then new high
school students I would love that you
know because that to me is like a recipe
for Success versus like trying to
recreate old shows with new characters
like Fuller house was a decent way of
doing that yeah but also they had the
same cast so that was uh but they phased
out a lot of the older like Bob Saget
like they weren't on they were on like
the first episode but then it was really
just DJ Stephanie and the neighborhood
whatever her name was that so that's not
a reboot that's a like a reunion almost
no it's a reboot because
than their kids on the show became
characters like right it's like Raven's
home it's like Raven's on it but it's
not really about Raven it's about like
the kids you know Gossip Girl Is that a
reboot yes but Gossip Girl they don't
have any of the old characters no so I
don't know what it's called when like
they bring back the young people from
the old show and make them the old
people now right that is something else
it's like a continuation of the show
yeah
it's a reboot it's a reboot yeah
anyways I think I'll take a Glee reboot
at any time as long as coach Coach Sue
and Mr shoe and it's a great way to
teach kids about like different musical
genres music eras you know so much of
what I know we were just talking about
this like from you know Fleetwood Mac
like I know all these songs because of
Glee Prince and I when I I remember
sitting down for the episodes and the
like today's lesson is like Michael
Jackson I'm like Ugh Michael Jackson
then you end up really liking and like
having a respect that was a bad example
because like Michael Jackson's like
hella problematic but like I can't keep
using the Fleetwood Mac but like Journey
yeah right like you would you would
leave the episode it was really like
educational with an enormous respect for
this older band that like your parents
used to listen to and you didn't really
care about right in addition to just
learning many things about you know the
world I feel like it was really like a
huge show like how the cultural impact
it was just I mean the episode on the
school shooting that was like one of
like that was a cultural reset for me it
was the craziest episode I don't
remember that but their later episode
um no no because they were
all still in school because Brittany was
there maybe actually yes it was some of
the Glee project characters and like a
gun went off and all the kids like went
into
drill mode but it was like there wasn't
an actual active shooter like somebody
brought a gun to school and it just like
fired in the locker and like whatever
um but it was the whole time you're
watching the episode you think that
there is an active shooter it was a very
good episode see we're just like
tackling difficult issues David that
jock who tried to commit suicide like
they were really I feel like it was a
very good educational show and kids
could use that these days yeah it was a
great show great job
uh so I look forward to other news that
comes out from the past podcast yeah are
you ready for our next story what number
is it four
yeah I'm ready is it the story that's
brought to you oh by Thrive Cosmetics
yes it is high performance Beauty and
skin care products that are made with
Clean Skin loving ingredients yes ma'am
that's why Thrive Cosmetics is amazing
they have no power bins no sulfates no
flashlights it is certified 100 vegan
and cruelty free
um and it's Thrive Cosmetics for a
reason because every purchase supports
an organization that helps communities
Thrive so I feel like I've known about
Thrive Cosmetics I didn't know a lot
about them but I bought their mascara
off of a Facebook ad like a couple years
ago because it was literally too good to
be true and it was so fabulous and then
I started buying a lot more of their
products and becoming more familiar with
the company and like they're
philanthropic efforts and I thought it
was really cool so the mascara that I
was just talking about is still like one
of their best selling products it's
called the liquid lash extensions
mascara so it's a vegan tubing mascara
it's their best selling product they
have over 20 000 five-star reviews their
formula is proprietary it'll
dramatically lengthen each lash from
root to tip it mimics the look of lash
extensions but it doesn't damage with
glue or expensive slime prices it's
clean nourishing ingredients support
longer stronger and healthier looking
lashes over time also a huge best seller
for them is their brilliant eye
brightener it's a cream to powder
highlighter stick that brightens and
opens Eyes giving you an instant eye
lift I saw this product all over Tick
Tock before I bought it everyone was
like doing their makeup and it was
really like you could use it on a
million different parts of your face I
love buying a makeup product that like
can be five different things because
like why just be one you're a waste of
space in my counter and on my travel
size bag
um also they're hydrating lip tint it's
the sheer strength hydrating lip tint
will deeply hydrate your lips with a
hint of a tint that applies evenly and
lasts for over six hours so bigger than
Beauty which is their philanthropic
effort so for every product purchase
Thrive Cosmetics is going to donate to
help communities Thrive they have over
300 giving Partners across the country
and they support numerous causes so you
know that you can be buying beautiful
clean products that are going to make
you look sickening and then also know
that that money is going to be put back
to work to your community now is a great
time to try Thrive Cosmetics for
yourself right now you can get 15 off
your first order when you visit
thrivecosmetics.com toast that's Thrive
Cosmetics spelled
c-a-u-s-e-m-e-t-i-c-s.com slash toast
for 15 off your first order
thrivecosmetics.com
toast great our next story is a little
more celebrity Halloween news Heidi Klum
dressed as a worm for her annual
Halloween party I feel like really
um
I have sympathy for Heidi Klum yeah she
got herself into this role this Wormhole
precise maybe that's what this is
signifying oh maybe it's metaphor
because it's like years and years and
years ago she had like the biggest and
baddest Halloween party on the planet
and every celebrity went yada yada and
she was truly cool and she always I
really outdid it it was her party she
did this crazy costume and then it
became like
a corporate Affair over the last like
couple of years I've been twice it's one
of the worst parties everything is like
you want a free razor sponsor it's like
it's just so tacky it's not like I think
she makes a lot of money from it good
for her so it's not like a fun social
event that a lot of celebrities go to
actually Elon Musk went this year which
is like the biggest celebrity to go in
years because I was invited so did he
dress up as some like you know superhero
I don't know he looks he looks um he's
getting in shape he looks like kind of
hot Bachelor
um
so it's not like this fabulous event and
I feel like now she's in a place where
she has to do it every year and like
maybe she makes some money and it's like
good for her press but she doesn't want
to do it anymore and she keeps out doing
herself you know she did the clones and
then she did Jessica Rabbit and the
Prosthetics and now she just had a place
where she's tired no and like the
costumes are getting more extreme and
stupid and it's like I it's what I'm
saying like I do not know what you are I
mean I guess I know what a worm is but
like what's that so she then she wore
like a big prosthetic worm that like
attached to her face seamlessly so like
you could really only see the slits of
her eyes yeah she was like really well
done it was great special effects makeup
and then she went inside and took it off
but left the face worm on I was walking
around the party with a face worm and a
crystal body suit yeah I just feel like
she's tired she's tired and you know
what so where are we hiding it's the
21st it's like a Halloween party but I
think she makes a lot of money yeah no
I'm sure that she does but the costumes
are just
insane and I'm glad to know what a worm
is so like that's good right usually
it's just like some like a obscure
obscure not even obscure it's just like
a bunch of Prosthetics like to be
something that I have no idea what that
is right so I just feel like the party's
gone downhill over the last couple of
years and I feel like she should really
do one more like go out with a bang make
it actually cool and I'm sorry like
doing it in New York like no one cool
lives here like you really gotta do it
in L.A if you want it to be like pop in
with celebs I think she needs to go she
needs to have a final one like I think
she needs to retire this
and that's just how I feel I don't know
if she would it was sponsored by now
screaming X Prime video and Bailey's
Irish cream liqueur
group hospitality's forthcoming modern
Japanese restaurant saki nohana she also
partnered with trick or treat UNICEF USA
to help raise awareness for its annual
Halloween Campaign which raises money
for children in need according to a
press release lovely it's a lot of work
is what I'm hearing and 10 hours in the
chair to be a worm right right and like
you could go to Spirit Halloween right
like we did and we didn't look low
budget at all no us low budget no never
ever it's not a possibility I don't even
know those words
um but speaking of Halloween we got a
few more celeb Halloween costumes so
let's just go through them we had
Kendall Jenner Jenner dressed as a
cucumber cute like
cute cute yeah yeah
um I think one of the best costumes was
clueless star Donald
dressed up as Dion and he was himself
his character I first of all his
daughter is adorable her costume was
Perfection like literally I could not
find one thing wrong she literally
looked like Stacey Dash did 10 years ago
15 years ago
um winner winner chicken dinner and like
I love the cultural reference I love
it's his own movie she's adorable I
could not best best rest honestly best
dress agreed um lizzo was Miss Piggy in
a new costume really cute Machine Gun
Kelly and Megan Fox Were Us
a priest and something like being very
sacrilegious people I think were
offended
um yeah I mean if that was my religion
like I like I would be [ __ ] annoyed
but like I was looking at this and it's
like I feel like they wanted to offend I
feel like maybe they wanted to start a
conversation just like drum something up
what is she dressed as like I don't know
what the relationships it's like dubstep
fairy right now it's like latex sexy
like
um latex sex like it's like a it's like
she looks like a dominatrix it's like a
bikini yeah and she said um on Sundays
we take communion so they're just like
oh that's kind of rude religious people
are they religious no that's what they
are so I'm asking like are they or like
not that I've seen I just think when it
comes to Halloween
I think
avoiding religion is like a general like
a good general rule of thumb like don't
dress as a rabbi don't dress as like an
Arab shake like don't don't dress like
this but I think sometimes people do a
costume and then like they find out
afterwards like oh like that I offended
someone but right like when Harry Hamlin
wore swastika I'm sure he was really
um but these are here in the next day
and this costume like they want to
offend yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
this the intention was to stir up right
because it's not like he even looks like
a a traditional Priest No but I just
think like if you have to question your
costume maybe don't
no but like that that was the point for
them I said what up is the vibe I'm
getting there are a lot of um Halloween
like missteps in Hollywood honestly I
think one of the craziest things ever
because it was not even that long ago
was when Julianne Hough did blackface
like that was psychotic yeah and of
course Prince Harry Nazi you see some
guy dressed as a Nazi in SoHo and like
was being kicked out of local
establishments yeah a lot of I saw like
a lot of
videos and pictures of people dressed as
Nazis this year and it's just not the
Bob no stop no stop it's not cute
Thanksgiving
it's giving
what is it giving it's getting moronic
that's what it's giving yeah
um yeah those are just a few that come
to mind of course you know Luanne de
lesseps says Princess Diana and not
Princess Diana Diana Ross
not sure if that was blackface but it
was a little too close yeah old too
close
so I'm glad Halloween's over personally
like I'm done yeah that's a wrap on
Halloween and I hadn't seen elon's
costume but now I see it he's looking
good he's just dressed like I can't
believe he went to that party I know
it's like it's such a it really is like
a low budget party it's like it's never
really that star-studded it hasn't been
in years and maybe it was just like in
town in New York he brought his mom yeah
and they were like for like a family fun
friendly party we checked his email what
Halloween parties have I been invited to
I just feel like he's like oh Heidi Klum
right maybe he's like interested in
Heidi even though Heidi has a boyfriend
Heidi or he would just like didn't know
yet that it's just a PR event like right
he thought it was going to be right
because you he excuse me oh my God you
hear like wow Heidi klum's starting a
Halloween party sponsored by Amazon
Prime like it does sound pretty pretty
stoning yeah but it's not it's not
really not are you ready for our fifth
and final story a little behind the
scenes news from Andy about the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills reunion okay
he's revealing the contents of Lisa
rinna's untouched reunion envelope oh
yes she brought like a yellow envelope
yeah so uh Andy addressed fans lingering
desperation to know what was inside the
untouched manila envelopes Lisa Rinna
brought with her to set that day where
did he address this right away his radio
Andy Show he said that the envelopes
contained receipts relating to the Elton
John AIDS Foundation ticket snafu he
said well we just wound up cutting it
all out there were a lot of decisions
made in the edit to cut down many
conversations he said every topic from
the season was not only discussed that
day but also Beat to Death informing
viewers at the group film for a very
long time and talked about a lot he said
we had a lot to get to in three episodes
if the reunion had been any longer I
feel like people would have complained
that it was too long but now people are
complaining why didn't you talk about
this more why didn't you talk about that
more actually like I don't really care
that that it was the Elton John stuff
and that they cut it out but we did
spend so much time on that and like Lisa
Rinna really was the villain in that
story too yeah and I think the whole
point was missed of the Elton John thing
which was like not whether or not you
bought the table who paid for this or
that which is that Lisa Rinna took them
and they didn't say thank you in the way
that Lisa was asking ourselves to say
thank you for a jar of sauce about the
sauce no the point was completely lost
on everyone completely lost now it's
about like this Elton John thing who
paid who goes not about that like who
bought the table
not about that not about that I'm glad
that they skipped it because it's
infuriating
um then and it would have been
infuriating that and they resolved it on
the show so I really feel like when
something is resolved on the show in a
real way I agree I don't need to dig it
up again I completely agree also Brady
Mandy's like always making
noise news yeah so John Mayer was on
radio Andy talking about midnights I saw
that you were watching that I was
watching that um he said a whole bunch
of nothing but basically
um somebody brought up midnights and
John was like yeah no like I went and
listened to it um one he was nice he was
like one because she's like talented and
two you know you're always like looking
for yourself
um
and he's like I do think like we reached
a point you know what is it like 10 15
years where like it's like kind of crazy
to be like still singing about that
relationship
um like beating a dead horse kind of
he's like but whatever like he was like
he was pretending to be cool with it but
he was also like not and I mean he's not
wrong but like that's the Taylor way
like you're gonna you're gonna hurt me
like bet I'll make it your [ __ ]
problem forever [ __ ] how long were they
in a relationship for it's it wasn't
ever formalized like we weren't we they
never publicly stepped out like like how
long were they not talking but it's so
um
it's so
traumatizing for her because like like I
think she sees it as like a situation
where she was taken advantage of because
she was so young like what happened he
was she's 19 he's big and old they wrote
a song together he thought she was so
great and I think he just like was like
like inappropriate in like his pursuit
of her given the difference in their
like levels of power levels of age and
in the words of Taylor Swift give me
back my girl hood it was mine first
Coulda Woulda Shoulda I think that's
about John whenever she refers like
being 19 that's about John and how old
was she with Jake Gyllenhaal 21. okay oh
so he took the girlhood before Jake
because I was gonna say like I feel like
Jake so I was thinking that that maybe
that song was about Jake Gyllenhaal
because we know Jake Gyllenhaal took her
virginity
um but I don't think she was talking
about virginity in in the word girl and
I think she was talking about her
innocence yes so um I do think that
could Woulda is still about John Mayer
because she talks about being 19 and 19.
don't you think 19's too young to be
placed with the girl in the dress cried
the whole way home if you want to know
what went on between her and John it's
like just listened to that song I think
she was like he took an interest in her
she couldn't [ __ ] believe it she's
like this young on this new on the scene
girly and he just like was [ __ ] mean
to her and like played with her and she
was like became obsessed because like
when you're 19 and John Mayer wants to
like hang out with you of course you're
gonna become obsessed so like do you
think they ever kissed yeah yeah I just
I don't think they had sex okay okay but
like it was romantic I think it was like
a fling but for him but it was like one
of many flings and for her
it was her whole world she's like newly
famous she's 19 like and he's such a
respected artist like so you have to
think of it from the art point of view
where it's like this person who's like I
respect so much thinks my art is great
and there's a video compilation I will
find it for you
um in like the months that they like
wrote half of my heart together were
hanging out before I think they really
started they like did a bunch of press
together not press but like events
songwriting conventions and he's like
tapped with introducing her he just like
speaks about her in a few different
instances
so lovingly like he's so taken by her
talent and her presence and her beauty
so somebody stitched together like all
the times in that year where he like you
know introduced her at an award show or
did something and it's like glowing like
to hear John Mayer talk about you like
that it's it's breathtaking like I wish
you would talk about me like that
um
and what he was saying in the interview
was like yeah there's a lot of [ __ ]
out there I don't think I'm like the
biggest [ __ ] of all of them like I
don't really think what I did was that
like crazy so it's like to still be
talking about it 10 or 15 years later it
seems excessive I agree with that as
well I agree with that as well um
they're doing construction on Jackie's
house so it's time to end the podcast
yeah it sounds like we're in New York
yeah so I can't escape it anywhere
um thank you guys so much for listening
to the toast the Monday Morning Show
where we deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please don't
forget to subscribe and give this video
a thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
at Spotify iTunes digital public radio I
hear radiocast box all the places where
we listen to podcasts find dust the
toast and leave a five-star review about
how wickedly talented we are wickedly
have an amazing day we'll see you
tomorrow for hump day oh yeah